rubbish fanzine is a project that
started because we just wanted to
document our lives although we didn't
have a clear idea how we want to do that
but we know that it had to be in the
publication of sort because we like
books very much at home the whole
process from the beginning was always
the fall of us sitting down together
we've all got books and papers and just
writing our ideas and we'll go through
them together all fathers are always
involved from the beginning for our
friends in issue tree forever and a day
how it all started was because we had
this old biscuit tin at home that we
used to put on family stuff so when we
saw that and we wanted to do issue tree
we looked at the tea never said if the
zine would be inside this team they'll
be so cool I like sitting in a circle
working with my family because you know
it just feels cozy I like going to many
places with my family to carry out all
these activities because I get to spend
much more time with my family the
designing of rubbish actually there is
no philosophy we really just want to put
things that we feel honest about things
that that meant something to us and when
put together we look at it and it's like
a this is and something that were not
seen before the president's desire what
is the highest accolade in Singapore
creativity and that will probably be to
some the benchmark Apollo when Dan came
back home tell us that yes I think God
award I think they were really in
disbelief having read and I rub giving
us the content giving us their ideas and
their feelings into this is a very big
part of Hope MC
I will always tell emerging designers
that firstly the heart must beat their
ups and downs are just challenges but if
we can look beyond their this marriage
of your work is a lifelong commitment so
if you love something then you just got
to do something for Darby
you